yes i somehow managed to get my hands
on a ps5 this holiday season and boy
do i have a launch story for you from a
crazy pre-order experience where i ended
up with
two ps5s to my first impressions of the
new dual sims controller my favorite
launch games and one
thing that really surprised me all that
and more in today's video
and we're starting right now
now today we're going to talk about my
pre-order experience
the actual arrival of my ps5 the dual
sense controller
the games and then my one big surprise
now if you want to jump to any of these
points in the video i'm going to include
chapter markers down
in the description below alternatively
you'll also find links
to all these points in the video in the
timeline below
people of the internet retrorec and tour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream
over on twitch so from the very moment
sony announced the price and release
date for ps5 everyone knew it was going
to be an insanely hard item to find
of course they held their showcase event
back on september 16th and also
announced the price
and release date what happened after
that was just a complete
fiasco there's really no other way to
say it sony told everyone pre-orders
would be going live the following day on
september 16th
but then walmart jumped the gun and put
theirs up early
once that happened it quickly became an
all-out free-for-all as retailers
started listing their pre-orders at
random times throughout the day
now i happened to be on twitter way too
much so i kept my eye out and was quick
on the draw
anytime i saw these go for sale the
first pre-order i managed to secure was
through
target and i think amazon's pre-orders
went up that night
and because things were so hectic i
wanted to make sure i had this thing at
launch so i went ahead and pre-ordered a
second ps5 with amazon
knowing that as launch got closer i
could always cancel if need be well as
november 12th approached i talked to my
wife's cousin who happened to be looking
for a ps5
i told him about my second pre-order and
he said he'd buy it from me so that's
why i ended up keeping both
orders now despite having two pre-orders
i still didn't get
either on launch day or even the day
after my amazon pre-order shipped the
morning of the 12th
and started out two hours away from
where i live it ended up going on a
six-day journey that saw it actually
make it into my city
only to travel further away before
finally coming back and then eventually
arriving
at my house the target pre-order
actually shipped
second but ended up arriving first which
ended up being on sunday
november 15th of course in hindsight
three days really isn't that long but in
the middle of all this i was mainly
afraid the order would be lost
completely or
stolen something crazy there were just
so many ridiculous stories online i
really wanted to have this thing in hand
in all seriousness though shout out to
all the retail and delivery workers who
are trying their best to keep things
going and what has been such a crazy
year for everyone
most people out there are just doing the
best they can so make sure you remember
that when you're dealing with any
delivery workers or retail
workers this holiday season really
anytime but especially this year
so once i finally got my ps5 the first
thing i was most anxious to see was just
how
hideous this thing looked in my office
look i love sony and the playstation
brand but initially i wasn't a huge fan
of the console design especially
compared to the ps4 which was just an
absolutely beautiful console especially
the first one
i gotta say though i found a pretty good
spot for it you can see here kind of
behind my tv but you see it poking out
just a little bit there and it's grown
on me somewhat
if you're someone who owns a pc or has
built your own pc it's much closer in
size to something like a mini itx build
or even a mid tower build
here's a picture of the ps5 next to my
fractal design
define mini c case and you can see it
actually makes the ps5 look
kind of small here of course next to any
home console though the ps5 will indeed
look like a
giant of a console once you find a good
place for it though you'll soon
quickly forget about the design anyway
and become far more concerned with how
this thing runs
both my ps4 and ps4 pro were insanely
loud at times especially with
graphically intensive games
the ps5 so far i've never heard it
except when a disk is
spinning so so far so good on that front
now let's get to the dual sense
controller which has just
blown me away video game controllers
have steadily improved and made slight
tweaks and changes to a format that
really started with the nes controller
back in 1983
shoulder buttons analog sticks rumble
these were all iterations that slightly
improve the way we play and experience
games
then in 2006 nintendo gave us something
radically different with the wii remote
it was just one of those sensations that
instantly made sense when you had it in
your hand for the first time
honestly i wasn't sure i would ever have
that feeling again of something on a
controller being
so radically different i gotta say
though the dual sense has proven me
wrong because it's
honestly incredible what this controller
can do don't get me wrong it doesn't
have that same
mass appeal like the wii but if you're a
gamer familiar with controllers
try one of these things as soon as you
can and i know right now that may be
easier said than done
but hopefully this whole pandemic will
eventually be over and ps5 will be
widely available and you can try it out
in a store somewhere
i already made a separate video talking
about how impressed i am with the free
pack in game astros playroom it's the
best showcase so far for the dual since
and also happens to be a fantastic
platformer as well
but what specifically makes the
controller so great
i want to try and paint a picture for
you guys out there because i know you
keep hearing this heck i kept hearing it
before launch
and now that i have it in my hands i
want to do the best i can to help you
all get an actual feel for what this
thing can do
so for starters the triggers sony calls
them adaptive triggers and what they're
able to do with these things just
doesn't even
feel like it should be possible so far
no game that i've played does this
better than
astros playroom so just to kind of start
as a frame of reference
imagine the ps4 trigger maybe with a
little bit more resistance to it
and then imagine that that resistance
can change imagine that the trigger can
actually push back at times then imagine
as you press down that the trigger can
actually change
its level of resistance and it's not
just a matter of resistance or
no resistance it can actually change and
alter just how much resistance you're
feeling then there's the haptics here
it's all about
subtlety from giving you a sense of tiny
raindrops in astros play room to the odd
sensation of your controller
powering up when you defeat a boss in
demon souls this thing in demon souls
guys it's so
bizarre yet satisfying and it's it's
such a small thing but it's when you
defeat a boss and then activate a new
archstone
the only way i can describe it is that
it's exactly what you would imagine a
controller would feel like
if it kind of sucked up a powerful force
into it it's not a vibration you just
kind of get this satisfying feedback
from the whole controller like it's
pushing out
a little force in every direction it's
so
incredibly subtle but that i think is
what makes it work so well
and you can't forget about the overall
build quality in general
the dual shock 4 still feels pretty good
to me but there's no denying the overall
build quality of the dual sense is far
superior then you have the dualshock 3
which honestly feels like one of my
son's plastic toy controllers at this
point it's
crazy as far as the games go i've beaten
both astros playroom as well as demon
souls and have started spider-man miles
morales
i've also played a handful of ps4 titles
on the system and have tried out some
fan favorites like fortnite and destiny
in short demon souls is absolutely a
phenomenal launch game
even though it's a remake this is one
that was absolutely warranted
i had honestly forgotten how good this
game is which is crazy considering how
big a fan i am of from software
its level design is outstanding and even
after i beat it i actually found myself
itching to dive back in for another
playthrough which i don't usually do
with the from games even though i love
them
you guys already know i think astro is
great and what i've played so far of
miles morales has been good as well
now one thing that's really surprised me
that i didn't expect and that is how
much better the ps5 makes
a lot of your old ps4 games now this
isn't a given with every game so you'll
have to look into this on a case-by-case
basis when it comes to your favorite
games
but take ghost of tsushima for example
which had both a performance mode and
fidelity mode for ps4 pro
now you can get a solid 60fps experience
in the fidelity mode when you're playing
on ps5 that's right
not the performance mode in ghost of
tsushima the fidelity mode
there's also days gone which feels like
an entirely different game now with the
rock solid frame rate
most of these games require a patch from
the devs but if there are any games that
originally had unlocked frame rates they
don't need any patch at all to see some
improvement
you'll also get a bunch of these games
right away if you're a playstation plus
member as they are part of the
playstation plus collection
god of war is another that runs better
now but they could actually make this
one even better if they patched an
update for it
right now the only way to get 60fps in
that game is to run it at its
performance mode which does drop the
resolution
now this doesn't mean that the ps5 is
incapable of running it at the higher
frame rate and higher resolution it's
just that they haven't patched it in
there
two big titles that don't see all that
much of an improvement at least right
now
are the last of us part two and of
course fan favorite
bloodborne here's to hoping we get
something in the future
on both of those as far as any downsides
go the ui is taking some time to get
used to
overall i like the look and feel of it
but there's quite a bit lacking
at the moment there are no themes or
folders certain items have moved around
from where you'd come to expect them on
ps4 and were still waiting on promise
features such as variable refresh rates
if you have an hdr supported tv you
should know the ps5 will
always run in hdr mode even when playing
ps4 games that didn't have an hdr mode
this means those ps4 games are actually
being displayed through an hdr container
now this is a departure from the ps4
which you may remember would only kick
on the hdr when loading into a game that
supported it
if you remember that little flicker of a
black screen and then the hdr logo would
pop
up or vice versa that's what was
happening there now i personally haven't
noticed a huge difference but i'm also
not comparing this side by side to my
old ps4
you should definitely take the
opportunity though to make sure your
tv's hdr mode is calibrated
to your ideal settings and ultimately if
it bothers you too much you can always
disable hdr from the ps5 menu
which then in turn will leave those old
ps4 games looking exactly like they did
on ps4 theoretically all that being said
i've certainly
enjoyed my time with the ps5 so far and
believe this generation is shaping up to
be another
amazing one for sony fans if you have
any questions at all about the ps5 let
me know down in the comments
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon